Did you know that your hormones and your cycle
are gonna affect your home school
more than anything else? It might sound crazy,
but it's true, because it affects you,
and you set the tone for your home.
As women, our cycle affects everything about us.
Things like our mood, energy,
emotions, how protective we are,
how we feel about ourselves.
And all of those things play a role in our homes.
Because when we're feeling our best,
we show up as our best. And vice versa,
we're not feeling great. It's hard to put our best foot forward.
I know for me, the week before my cycle,
I have zero patience. And when it starts,
I have no energy. And both of those drastically affect how I teach.
But the good thing is, I know this about myself,
so I can set my expectations accordingly.
When I don't have patience,
I don't teach hard concepts,
and I stick to familiar activities.
We do games and activities and things my kids already know how to do.
And I don't incorporate new things during this time.
And when I know I'm gonna be tired,
I stick to the basics. We do low stress activities,
a lot of lounging, a lot of reading.
Best thing you can do as a homeschool mom is start cycle sinking